[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la mondialisation vote elle
comptait parmi les victimes du
coronavirus faut-il relocaliser chez
nous sur le territoire français une
partie de notre production considérée
comme stratégique
faut-il réindustrialiser la france
faut-il davantage de protectionnisme
pour en débattre nous avons invité
jean-michel 4 points journaliste
économique alors il a été au monde à
l'âge est fier à la tribune à la lettre
à en 2017
il a cosigné dans le figaro l'appel
intitulé europe la supranationalité a
échoué faisant confiance aux nations
sinon c'est l'auteur d' alstom scandale
d'état et avec natacha polony de
délivrez nous du bien alto nouveaux
inquisiteurs aux édition de
l'observatoire janvier chez le 4e point
il faut re localiser d'après vous c'est
là c'est à la mode mais je pense que le
débat ne date pas d'aujourd'hui sur la
mondialisation je pense que c'est pas la
mondialisation qui va s'arrêter c'est la
globalisation et qu'on va des globalisé
la globalisation c'est un concept à dire
un seul monde
l'uniformisation du monde sous les
normes américaines en quelque sorte
d'énorme des multinationales ça ça va
être remis en cause
mais la mondialisation elle va continuer
parce qu'on ne va pas arrêter du jour au
lendemain la libre circulation des
marchandises ni des capitaux ni même des
hommes encore que la libre circulation
des hommes elle c'est elle qui va
souffrir le plus
au cours des prochaines années nicolas
bouzou
vous vous dirigez un cabinet de conseil
vous êtes l'auteur deux économistes un
parent dont vous êtes l'auteur de
pourquoi la lucidité habitent à
l'étranger de l'innovation sauvera le
monde et vous venez de publier
inventons la mondialisation de demain
aux éditions de l'observatoire
il faut relocaliser d'après vous savez
en quoi et ça dépend comment si l'idée
c'est de dire on va relocaliser tout un
tas de choses quitte à ce que les coûts
de production et donc les prix pour le
consommateur soit plus élevé ce sera des
relocalisations en pure perte parce que
celui qui décidera in fine et c'est le
consommateur et si on met de l'argent
privé de l'argent public pour
relocaliser alors qu'il n'y a pas
d'acheteur derrière on aura gaspiller
inutilement de l'argent si en revanche
l'idée c'est de dire il ya des secteurs
qui sont des secteurs dans lesquels on a
besoin d'avoir de la production sur le
sol français pas pour des raisons
économiques mais pour des raisons par
exemple d'indépendance sanitaires je
pense par exemple à la pharmacie à
certains segments de la pharmacie en
particulier à certains types
d'antibiotiques
si l' on dit on met en place une loi qui
oblige certains produits à être tout ou
partie s'abriter sur le sol français
là j'ai rien à dire on a fait ça on a un
décret que c'est pas une loi mais arnaud
montebourg avait fait ça pour protéger
le capital des entreprises dans les
secteurs jugés stratégiques très bien on
peut imaginer que ce qui a été fait pour
protéger le capital d'entreprises se
soit fait pour protéger un peu de
production sur le sol français mais je
le répète pas pour des raisons
économiques mais pour l'art et l'idée
qu'on peut se faire de l'indépendance
nationale
on y reviendra au cours de cette
émission alors de colle à la pandémie de
kovy date elle était révélatrice sur le
plan économique pour vous alors ou au
niveau global am pas seulement en france
jean-michel quatre points on va c'est la
fragilité des chaînes de valeur
je crois que on a vu qu'à un moment
donné les multinationales s'en sont
rendus compte d'ailleurs que la chine
s'est arrêtée d'abord et ça a commencé
par bloquer les chaînes
d'approvisionnement sur tout le reste du
monde
ensuite le monde s'est arrêté
et je crois que aujourd'hui dans les
grands groupes tout le monde étudient
une certaine recompte in antal isation
dire qu'effectivement la mondialisation
ne s'arrêtera pas en revanche on va
recompter continental is et les
entreprises et grandes entreprises vont
revoir leur chaîne de valeur
identifier les sous-ensembles les sous
ensembles et sous traitants qui ou des
produits sont stratégiques et dont elles
dépendent et elles vont les relocaliser
sur les continents et avoir ce qu'on
appelait autrefois c'est la trilatérale
vous aviez l'ensemble amérique
l'ensemble asie et l'ancien l'ensemble
europe eh bien je pense qu'on va
assister à une rencontre dans ta
lisation et que on va être plus près du
consommateur et produire plus pour le
consommateur et revanche aura toujours
des liens effectivement je pense que
l'industrie textile ne va pas sera
relocalisée comme par miracle
en france il y aura certains segments de
l'industrie textile qui se relocalise
rond mais je veux dire un mot sur les
relocalisations
on a redécouvert un concept je pense que
emmanuel macron avait redécouvert
lui-même yahoo 2 ans celui de la
souveraineté
alors il parle de souveraineté nationale
et de souveraineté européenne
mais la souveraineté c'est essentiel on
a découvert effectivement que la
souveraineté en matière de médicaments
et de santé c'était important
or ça fait quand même quelques années
que à sa tante de gens savent que la
plupart des médicaments sont délocalisés
en asie non seulement les excipients
mais aussi les principes actifs et que
on travaille avec le zéro stock en flux
tendu et bien c'est ça qui est
effectivement va falloir remettre en
cause
de la même façon il ya des souverainetés
à reconquérir dans l'agroalimentaire
indiscutablement dans la défense il faut
reconquérir certains aspects certains
composants essentiels et aussi en
matière de numérique d'électronique et
là c'est un vaste sujet parce que nous
avons laissé depuis 25 ans le monopole
de la microélectronique et du numérique
et aux américains et pas seulement aux
chinois d'ailleurs mais à un certain
nombre d'acteurs notamment asiatiques et
les européens ont laissé tomber les semi
conducteurs c'est essentiel on va voir
ça en détail
comment sont pas les médicaments nicolas
bouzou 60 à 80 % des médicaments
consommés en france et en europe
d'ailleurs sont produits en asie en inde
et en chine ce qui donne parfois des
ruptures de stock assez grave a juste
avant l'épidémie en 2019 y avait mille
quatre cent cinquante cas
d'indisponibilité de médicaments si on
remonte à à un an avant il y en avait eu
que 8 168 et si on monte à 10 heures
avant il n'y en avait eu que 44 donc là
tout à coup on a découvert que là
c'était grave effectivement il faut
relocaliser
vous êtes d'accord avec jean michel le 4
points il faut relocaliser alors déjà je
suis pas d'accord avec le fait qu on a
découvert tout ça je pense que la crise
l'a révélé mais en réalité la crise du
coroner virus elle n'a pas révélé grand
chose par le fait que le marché des
progrès un cru était pas bien régulé
mais au niveau global
ça a plutôt res a illustré des choses
qu'on savait déjà sur la question du
secteur pharmaceutique c'est plus
compliqué qu'il n'y paraît parce qu'en
fait en france on fait encore pas mal de
médicaments et on n'en exporte encore
beaucoup mais on fait des virements à
très forte valeur ajoutée ce qui est un
segment extrêmement important parce
qu'il ya une révolution thérapeutique
aujourd'hui très importante dans le
monde dans le domaine de la cancérologie
dans le domaine des maladies génétiques
rares
il ya vraiment des choses tout à fait
nouvelles qui sont basées sur l'analyse
qu'on peut faire du génome par exemple
et dans ce domaine
en france on fait des choses et on
exporte des choses
en fait ce qui a été délocalisé ce sont
des productions qui sont des productions
à plus faible valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire des médicaments assez
classique à ces vieux qui sont éprouvés
depuis longtemps comme vous avez cité
certains antibiotiques la pénicilline
par exemple c'est fait à 90 % en chine
parce que voilà c'est quelque chose
qu'on maîtrise les plus production sont
pas très élevées les molécules elles
sont génériques et et s'est pas
complètement idiot comme stratégie de
dire on fait ce qui est à forte valeur
ajoutée et on importe qui à plus faible
valeur ajoutée que je rappelle quand
même une des problématiques de
l'économie française c'est d'arriver
justement à montée en valeur ajoutée
pour avoir des bons salaires des bons
emplois et etc
donc voyez la problématique elle est
moins économique que politique
hier que la question qui se pose c'est
au fond comment est ce qu'on peut non
pas forcément produire sur le site
français de la pénicilline pour prendre
cet exemple mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut être sûr qu'on aura toujours à une
autre disposition de la pénicilline ou
d'autres types de molécules entre
guillemets l'entrée de gamme et ça ça
passe essentiellement par une
diversification de nos sources
d'approvisionnement dire que très
clairement beaucoup d'entreprises se
sont fait piéger non pas parce que elle
importait des biens intermédiaires mais
parce que pour le dire clairement pour
mettre les pieds dans le plat
tout était produit en chine est souvent
sur un site unique
prenez le secteur de l'automobile par
exemple peut-être qu'on en parlera plus
tard mais les pédales de francs elles
sont quasiment toutes produites en chine
alors si vous n'avez pas de de
frein bas et même si vous avez tout le
reste vous pouvez pas mettre sur le
marché une automobile donc vous voyez
en fait ce qu'il faut arriver à faire
mais on va y aller et ça ça va se faire
un peu tout seul en fait ça va se faire
sous la pression des actionnaires qui
veulent pas se laisser piéger une
deuxième fois mais il faut que les
entreprises diversifie davantage leurs
sources d'approvisionnement parce que là
très clairement le fait que la crise
touche la chine
c'est ça le point important la crise
elle a touché la chine des sites de
production chinois se sont arrêtés là
évidemment un certain nombre
d'entreprises chinoises ou non chinoises
se sont retrouvés complètement piégé
mais vraiment j'ai bon espoir parce que
je pense pas j'ai lu beaucoup de
dirigeants d'entreprise je pense que la
leçon a été compris la leçon était
comprise vous pensez aussi jean-michel 4
points oui je pense que de toute façon
les multinationales avaient déjà intégré
certaines localisations et chercher à -
un peu - des porn de la chine
le problème iwelt géopolitique qu'est ce
qui va se passer entre les états unis et
la chine
et entre le monde occidental et la chine
si on tend vers une nouvelle guerre
froide ce qui semble le cas à ce moment
là effectivement on ne peut pas dépendre
de la chine dont il va y avoir une
relocalisation d'un ensemble de
production encore une fois par grand
continent
le mouvement a été amorcé il va
s'accélérer cela dit on ne localise pas
comme ça du jour au lendemain c'est
compliqué et plus la technologie
et puis il ya de la valeur ajoutée plus
est complexe je reviens sur les semi
conducteurs puisque ça secteur clé une
usine de semi conducteurs c'est au bas
mot 10 milliards de dollars
d'investissements par an plaisait cran
serait reprise chinoise beta1 une sorte
de monopole des écrans toutes et tous
écrans des ordinateurs des zips à des i
phone et des téléviseurs behe a investi
50 milliards de dollars en 20 ans et
bien si on veut il faudra bien que on
relocalise en europe et aux états unis
en partie les fabrication d'écrans et
bien faudra accepter d'investir
alors ensuite il ya un problème du coût
et oui de toute façon il faudrait que le
consommateur peut être a shit mais à
chaque style un peu moins mais il
achètera des produits qui seront
peut-être de meilleure durabilité et qui
finalement il se retrouva bien venir un
changement dans le comportement des
consommateurs
le leb le low cost le bas prix n'est pas
le but ultime en soit vous le pensez
aussi nicolas bouzou vous le disiez
c'est les consommateurs à la fin qui
décide si la relocalisation et est
viable ou pas parce que le battery n'est
pas une fin en soi dans certains
secteurs je pense à l'alimentation par
exemple mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
il ya quand même très grande souffrance
économique et social qui est en train
d'arriver en france on a une vague de
chômage une vague de faillites
malheureusement très importante ce qui
est en train d'arriver vers nous
j'imagine que le sommet de la vague sera
pour le début de l'automne et tout ceci
va avoir des conséquences
macroéconomiques qui malheureusement
vont être relativement durable c'est à
dire que ce que l'on sait bien c'est que
quand on a une grosse vague de chômage
on a un marché du travail qui est
déséquilibré
et ça génère des pressions
déflationnistes notamment sur les
salaires donc on va avoir
malheureusement même s'il faut lutter
contre ça il ya des moyens de lutter
contre ça mais on évitera pas des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat
ces prochaines années donc je pense que
se dire que au fond l'étiquette made in
france va suffire à convaincre un
certain nombre de consommateurs
d'acheter
je pense que c'est vrai pour des
catégories de la population qui sont
privilégiés mais pour tous ceux qui vont
souffrir
c'est ces prochaines années la priorité
ce sera d'arriver à consommer un coup
qu'ils soient faibles
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on peut
faire des relocalisations à faible coût
ça commence à se faire d'ailleurs pas
encore beaucoup c'est le début mais
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'industrie 4.0
c'est à dire que si on arrive et ça la
politique économique plaidé hier mais si
on arrive à avoir des usines dans
lesquels on a beaucoup de gros vous
aimez réexamen qu'il a beaucoup
d'intelligence artificielle dans
lesquels on a des imprimantes 3d ce
qu'on appelle de la fabrication additive
et si tout ça fonctionne ensemble
là on est capable de produire des choses
de bonne qualité d'ailleurs dans des
quantités qui peuvent être est vraie vie
éventuellement relativement réduite et à
faible coût
alors le club gagne c'est que cette
technologie en france on les a pas
encore beaucoup on est moins bien
équipés que les finlandais les allemands
les sud coréens mais on peut quand même
aidé à ça et moi par exemple là je
préconise le gouvernement dans le cadre
du plan de relance 2021 enfin celui qui
sera dans la loi de finances 2021 donc
le grand plan de relance
je propose d'agir fiscalement sur
l'investissement alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails techniques mais
d'affaires de l'amortissement accéléré
sur l'amortissement fléchés vers les
robots les imprimantes 3d le numérique
l'intelligence artificielle regardez les
rambo c'est un sujet qui est absolument
fascinant parce que les robots dans une
usine
ça permet de produire à des coûts qui
sont relativement modérés et des robots
en france sur la part le taux de
cotisation des usines en france
il est absolument catastrophique donc ça
ça c'est une voie qui est intéressant
pendant le long confinement notamment
les français ont été absolument sidéré
on n'avait pas de masque on n'avait pas
de deux tests on n'avait pas non plus de
traçage informatique c'est ce qui nous a
obligé à nous confiner tout à fait
strictement à la chinoise avec les
conséquences incalculables que cela peut
avoir avec cela aura vous l'avais dit à
partir de l'automne mais le fait qu'on
n'était pas capable de fabriquer des
masques ni de fabriquer des tests ni
même de fabriquer une application tels
que stop qu'ovide qui est actuellement
débat l'assemblée
quelles conséquences dans avait tirez
vous jean-michel quatre points - les
conséquences que j'ai tirée de duke au
vide c'est le poids de la bureaucratie
et la bureaucratie sanitaire mais aussi
la biographie d'une façon générale je
pense que les français ont découvert
qu'ils avaient un état les français
aiment leur état mais qu'ils avaient un
état qui était devenu une caricature de
bureaucratie et c'est ça sur lequel il
va falloir réfléchir et que même je
crois que le président de la république
s'en est aperçu c'est à dire que c'est
pas seulement en france aux états unis
un peu partout un peu moins en allemagne
qui au contraire a montré que est
peut-être moins de bureaucratie qu'on ne
pouvait le penser
vous êtes le président vous avez une
idée vous voulez intervenir
vous appuyez sur le bouton ça ne répond
pas et ça ne répond pas parce que le
système bureaucratique refuse de
répondre parce que ça rentre pas dans
ces cases analyse dans ses grilles
d'analysé et ça c'est un handicap et
c'est le handicap que nous avons nous
avons désindustrialisé mais c'est un
choix que nous avons fait un stage choix
que nous avons fait à 25 ans et ce choix
il a été fait à la fois parce que ce
qu'on appelle les élites les classes
dirigeantes l'administration les grandes
entreprises mais aussi par la population
qui a effectivement arbitrer et choisit
d'avoir des produits choisis le
consommateur contre le producteur a mais
il se trouve que le producteur le
consommateur est aussi un producteur et
c'est comme ça qu'on a perdu un saturn
d'emploi et que l'on a transformé des
emplois à valeur ajoutée dans
l'industrie dans les emplois de service
low cost
aujourd'hui il faut réindustrialiser je
pense que tout le monde en est conscient
mais ça se fait pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain
est ce que la crise on peut profiter de
la crise pour montrer qu'il y a des voix
nécessaires alors ensuite ré
industrialiser ça implique un tous
s'impliquent le rôle de l'état mais
l'état doit faire sa révolution
l'administration doit faire sa
révolution et aussi il faut changer les
structures de l'état
il est inadmissible que l'industrie
dépendent de bercy ça c'est depuis ce 2
min strauss kahn
si vous voulez réindustrialiser la
france il faut avoir une grande
structure qui pilote avec les
entreprises qui va réinscrire de la
france c'est le collectif la
collectivité qui il faut ré revitaliser
le plan et ensuite ce sont les
entreprises sur le terrain qui vont
effectivement dire les entreprises
je pense l'attendent sont convaincus
mais il faut ensuite créer les
conditions de cette réinitialisation ça
passe dans la fiscalité ça passe aussi
par l'orientation de l'épargné
indiscutablement ça passe par la
formation
il faut que les emplois verts
l'industrie soit revitaliser y compris
dans le secondaire et à l'université
c'est tout un ensemble et ça c'est une
prise de conscience générale qu'on doit
avoir les pays qui ont le mieux résisté
aux que vides sont les pays qui étaient
industrialisés que ce soit le japon la
corée du sud taïwan l'allemagne ce sont
eux qui ont eu moins de décès qui s'en
sont mieux sortis nicolas bouzou
alors la planification elle existe un
peu en réalité elles marchent plutôt
bien il existe au niveau des régions ce
qu'on appelle les schémas régionaux de
d'innovation et d'investissements et
c'est très intéressant parce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs là dans la période actuelle
qui est un certain nombre de présidents
de région je pense à la région grand est
avec jean rottner la région de france
avec xavier bertrand se sont vraiment
emparée de la question industrielle avec
au fond des plans de relance par l'offre
avec sans doute des aides à
l'investissement qui me semble assez
bien fait a fait est assez pertinent la
planification 1 française n'a jamais été
très dirigiste moi c'est un terme qui me
fait pas peur parce que la planification
notamment sous le général de gaulle
quand on regarde les choses dans les
détails en fait de quoi s'agissait-il il
s'agissait de réunir des filières et de
faire en sorte que tout le monde aille
plutôt dans la même direction
on est un peu en train de refaire ça
aujourd'hui arnaud montebourg quand il
des ministres redressement productif la
baie de feist et les filières d'avenir
moi je trouvais ça plutôt pas mal il
faut répéter qu'on l'ait qu'on l'ait
abandonné
cela dit je crois pas que la
désindustrialisation elle soit liée à
une volonté je pense que l ailier tout
simplement de mauvaise politique
économique je crois qu'on a mené de
mauvaises politiques économiques depuis
vingt ans sur les questions d alors en
tout cas les choses se sont arrangées
mais trop récemment et peut-être de
façon pas suffisamment nette pour qu'on
en voit encore les effets positifs mais
disons que pendant longtemps on n'a pas
mené de bonnes petites innovations on a
laissé dériver ce qu'on appelle le coût
unitaire du travail c'est à dire que
soit la productivité elle n'est pas
assez vite soit les coûts salariaux
elle est allée trop vite on n'a pas
regardé tout ça on n'a pas aussi mené le
politique de qualification des gens pour
travailler dans l'industrie
et c'est encore un problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui si on parle de l'automobile
plus qu'ailleurs on est en train
d'essayer de faire en france une filière
sur l'hydrogène par exemple j'y suis
très favorable simplement on a beaucoup
de mal à trouver des gens qui sont
formés pour travailler sur ces
technologies qui sont complètement
nouvelle donc je crois que vraiment
c'est une question de politique
économique
les choses sont en train de s'arranger
là où moi j'appelle à des changements
qui sont plus profonds c'est au niveau
européen
je pense qu en europe on a deux
problèmes aujourd'hui déjà on n'a pas de
politique industrielle et politique
industrielle pour moi c'est pas du tout
un gros mot vous savez là au moment où
on se parle vous allez space x
le concurrent d'arianespace qui est en
train d'envoyer des gens dans l'espace
space x est une start up qui a été créée
il ya quoi il ya 15 ans aujourd'hui
c'est d'une des plus grosses entreprises
dans le domaine spatial dans le monde et
space x les régions du pays six qui sont
pas mieux que les gens d'arianespace
c'est pas ça le sujet c'est que space x
la nasa lui passent des commandes pour
des années et lui dit voilà tu
ravitailler la station spatiale
internationale pendant des années et
avec cet argent que tu gagnes du coup tu
peux investir dans des projets qui toi
tu intéresse comme essayer d'aller sur
mars et s'est effacé la première chose
la deuxième chose
c'est que space x ne souffre pas du
droit de la concurrence européen
le space x il envoie des fusées mais ils
fabriquent des fusées oui alors
qu'arianespace il envoie des fusées ils
fabriquent pas tuer et space x il peut
opérer une constellation de satellites
alors qu'en europe
oulala opérer une constellation de
satellites quand on envoie les fusées
c'est mal c'est pas possible c'est pas
dans ce schéma concurrentielles
européennes oui je crois que on peut
vraiment arrangé les choses mais ça
nécessite d'avoir de bonnes politiques
au niveau national les choses
s'arrangent desdits les régions ce
qu'elles font c'est bien l'état français
a pris conscience mais il ya maintenant
plusieurs années et va plutôt dans la
bonne direction
maintenant on a un grand sujet européen
mais plus prosaïquement ou plus
pragmatiquement nicolas bouzou
on n'avait pas de masque on aurait dû
les stocker on les a pas stocker peu
importe ça c'est le problème mais on
n'avait pas de masque on n'était pas
foutu d'en fabriquer certains se disent
il faut absolument qu'on soit capable de
fabriquer des masques au cas où ça
commence alors fabriqué des masques
fabriqués des tests c'est l'avenir de la
france se fabriquer des masques
fabriqués de test à votre vie non bien
sûr que non
mais le problème des masses nous dit on
les a pas stocker et donc vous vous
évacuer ça d'un revers de main alors que
c'est le problème
je peux avoir démasqué s'en fabriquer
des masques il me suffit de les acheter
donc en fait le problème des masques
c'est qu'on en a pas acheté et qu'on les
a pas stocker je jette la pierre à
personne dans ce mois je n'avais pas
prévu la crise du coc vide et donc
peut-être moi même si j'avais été en
charge de ce dossier je n'aurais pas
stocker de masques donc c'est ce que ce
que je dis là ce ne formule pas une
critique
simplement je dis la question c'est pas
celle de la fabrication des masques en
réalité puis si vous dites aujourd'hui
ah ben on a un virus respiratoires alors
on va fabriquer des masses on va
implanter des usines de masse de
l'argent public pour faire des maths
bon très bien simplement si la prochaine
crise c'est peu et sanitaires c'est pas
un virus respiratoires et puis si on
manque pas de masque mais si on manque
de seringues
qu'est ce qu'on va faire faire des
seringues avec du tissu une des
élastiques ça en fait on n'a pas besoin
d'une usine de masque on a besoin d'
usine capable éventuellement de
fabriquer des masses c'était
complètement différent
on n'a pas besoin de seringue on en a
besoin d' usine capable de faire des
fringues donc on a besoin
en réalité d'avoir une base industrielle
résignant voyez c'est ça c'est ça le
sujet ce qui est formidable c'est quand
lvmh nous dit ah ben moi je peux faire
du gel hydroalcoolique voyez ça c'est
super ça c'est très intéressant où quand
l entreprise nous dit je fais des
masques de plongée ben je peux aller
changer un peu et ça va faire des
masques pour les personnes souhaitant
donc on a besoin d'une base industrielle
pour des raisons économiques d'une part
pour des raisons d'indépendance d'autre
part mais cette base industrielle il
faut qu'elle soit résidente
donc j'en reviens à mon obsession de la
technologie on a besoin d'avoir une base
industrielle avec un niveau de
technologie hyper lv1 c'est à ça que ça
sert injustement l'imprimante 3d les
robots l'intelligence artificielle ia ça
sert à pouvoir faire ce dont on a besoin
les masques si on a des lignes de
masques très bien mais vous voyez
investir aujourd'hui dans une usine des
masses moi je ne sais rien je suis pas
épidémiologistes je suis pas médecin
mais je me demande si c'est pas préparé
la garde avant jean michel quatrepoint
nous reste deux minutes avant la pause
sur la question des masques et des tests
vous êtes d'accord avec nicolas bouzou
oui mais bon on avait quelques usines de
masque on les a faits on les a fermés
puisqu'on avait pratiquement plus de moi
ce qui m'a frappé c'est les allemands
les allemands avaient une politique de
respirateurs d'abord ils ont fait des
tests tout de suite
donc il avait une capacité industrielle
nous n'avons plus de capacité
industrielle et effectivement si vous
avez des usines vous pouvez les
transformer rapidement vouloir
transformer quelques unes rapidement si
vous n'avez plus du sinn vous pouvez pas
est transformé et vous ne créez pas une
usine comme ça toutes pièces donc il
faut reconstituer une base industrielle
et c'est à partir de cette base
industrielle que l'on pourra ensuite
s'adapter en fonction des événements et
de la résilience dans certains cas mais
il faut une base industrielle
c'est ça qui est absolument nécessaire
vous le disais on avait des usines de
masques j'ai vu à la télévision le le
méritas de cette usine qui avait fermé
il ya
deux ans je crois qu'ils deviennent
doucet les machines sont toujours là on
pourrait rouvrir l'usiné
et puis non ça semblait très mystérieux
et tout à coup c'est à dire que tout à
cotiser mais voilà non mais je vous
écris est ce que ces masques étaient
rentables par rapport à ce qu'ont
apporté de chine
est ce que il ya eu aussi un problème un
problème de commande je crois que l'état
n'a plus honorer ses commandes
donc si on veut rien du trias lisez
aussi il faut une politique de marchés
publics
il faut que l'état mette un peu la main
à la pâte notamment pour tout ce qui est
dans les domaines de haute technologie
il faut aussi que la commande publique
soit là pour aider c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les années 60 70
on a industrialisé la france à cette
époque grâce à une politique d'achats
publics
alors c'est vrai que la règle européenne
nous empêche de réserver des marchés
sauf dans le domaine de la défense
ah oui je crois un article 346 du des
traités qui permet sur les matériels de
défense de fer des marchés de gré à gré
peut-être qu'il faut dans certains
domaines
effectivement voir avec nos partenaires
européens si on peut étendre cet article
346 à quelques autres secteurs
ensuite il ya effectivement au niveau
européen il faut un partage des tâches
au niveau européen on ne va pas tout
faire en france on va partager les
tâches avec les européens il faut se
mettre d'accord sur ce qu'on partage
je vous interromps jean-michel ont fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après on
continue ce débat
[Musique]
on est allé faire ailleurs ce qu'on
voulait faire chez nous mais qui coûtait
trop cher à faire chez nous avons
aujourd'hui des usines qui ferment en
france pour se mettre dans les pays de
l'est en pologne en roumanie ailleurs
selon vous sommes nous allés trop loin
dans la mondialisation
le principal problème c'est c'est aussi
l'europe et l'euro on est allé trop loin
surtout dans la désindustrialisation
d'autres pays en france on trouve pas
mal de choses sauf que ça ne passe
jamais dans l'industrie ça pourrait
créer des emplois ça pourrait créer de
la croissance mais nous on recherche
pour la beauté de la recherche avant
tout le problème pour moi c'est la
méfiance globale de notre pays a les gaz
industriels
il faut soutenir les industriels c'est
pas les intellectuels de bersillon de
dire comment l'industrie serait c'est
les industriels qu'ils parlent de sahwa
et qu'il au front
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck ça que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
faut-il relocaliser c'est la question
que beaucoup se posent depuis le début
de la crise du coroner virus et c'est la
question que je pose à nicolas bouzou ya
jean michel 4 points depuis le début de
cette émission
peut-on se pose est d'ailleurs la
question sur vous êtes parler des la
microélectronique tout à l'heure jean
michel mois depuis le début de cette
crise je m'aperçois que tous les outils
informatiques auxquels j'ai eu recours
et auquel ont eu recours la plupart des
français la plupart des européens la
plus belle des habitants dans le monde
tout ce qui nous a permis de continuer
de communiquer entre nous de travailler
pour la plupart d'entre nous de faire
cette émission aujourd'hui alors que
vous n'êtes là ni l'un ni l'autre mais
tous ces outils informatiques sont
américains ou chinois
rien de français rien d'européen on a
totalement raté le coche est-ce que
c'est trop tard nicolas bouzou
je pense que c'est tard en tout cas ce
qui est clair c'est que cette crise a
considérablement renforcé l'impact et
les pouvoirs des gaffes a donc les alors
les gars fassent est un acronyme
maintenant c'est pas simplement google
avec facebook apple mais c'est aussi des
entreprises parfois anciennes d'ailleurs
je pense à microsoft et puis des
entreprises plus récentes comme comme
netflix parce que ces entreprises elles
étaient déjà des pourvoyeuse de service
de cette économie distant ciel auquel le
confinement nous a obligés à avoir
recours
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre et ce
qui est extrêmement pernicieux dans
cette affaire c'est que ces entreprises
fonctionnent avec ce qu'on appelle en
économie des rendements croissants ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que plus
elles sont grandes plus elles
grandissent l'économie la microéconomie
de la troisième révolution industrielle
c'est une micro économique est très
différente de celle du 20è siècle au 20e
siècle on a des rendements décroissants
ce qui est très intuitif d'ailleurs les
rendements décroissants ça veut dire que
plus vous courez plus bas score depuis
votre coeur s'essouffle et puis vous
ralentissez
aujourd'hui on est dans une économie des
rendements croissants plus vous courez
plus votre coeur ralentit puis vous
pouvez accélérer et donc de ce point de
vue là la crise du coc vide
elle a donné un coup d'accélérateur aux
gaffes à dont ils n'avaient pas besoin
puisqu'ils étaient déjà sur des
trajectoires naturellement extrêmement
rapide on a énormément de retard dans
ces domaines là quand vous regardez
l'économie européenne quand vous
regardez notre prospérité en europe on
est encore prospères le revenu par
habitant est très élevé pib par habitant
est très élevé mais il repose sur
l'économie du 20e siècle
il repose pas il repose très peu très
marginalement sur l'économie du xxième
siècle celle inverse de la chine
en chine c'est beaucoup plus
équilibré aux etats unis c'est un peu
plus équilibré aussi en europe on repose
encore notre prospérité repose encore
sur une ronde technologique du 20e
siècle
pour répondre à votre question qu'ils
ont retardé le moment d'y répondre parce
que en réalité
peut-être que je pense que c'est trop
tard mais en même temps il faut pas
baisser les bras parce que comme on est
dans une période où l'innovation
technologique est extrêmement rapide où
est ce qu'on appelle la destruction
créatrice est extrêmement rapide
ça veut dire qu'il existe quand même
toujours potentiellement des portes
d'entrée technologique pour une zone
géographique c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
batteries électriques je parlais tout à
l'heure de l'hydrogène voilà un secteur
qui me passionne parce que autant dans
le numérique je pense que
malheureusement même si les choses
peuvent évoluer mais les positions des
uns et des autres et la domination sino
américaines elle est déjà vraiment très
ancrée autant sur certaines autres
technologies par exemple dans l'énergie
voilà je pense que le jeu est un peu
plus ouvert et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'il faut jouer cette
carte
jean-michel 4 points oui je mettrais un
bémol on va on va essayer de simplifier
il ya le soft ce qu'on appelait le soft
c'est à dire que tout ce qui est le les
services de traitement des données
les américains sont en position non pas
de monopole parce que les chinois ont
développé leurs propres outils baidu et
alibaba tencent et c'est donc il ya
effectivement les deux sont présents en
revanche sur la microélectronique
c'est à dire sur le hard les chinois
sont des assembleurs ce ne sont pas des
inventeurs sauf sur l'été comme avec
huawai et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
les américains ont réagi parce que
européens et américains se sont laissés
distancer sur la 5g huawai à peu près
deux ou trois ans d'avancé sur la 5g et
c'est pour ça que américains veulent
bloquer huawai pour essayer de rattraper
leur retard pour le reste sur la
microélectronique
c'est à dire sur l'ensemble de la
filière des machines
des scanners etc qui fabrique les
composants électroniques et semi
conducteurs absolument indispensable à
toute l'électronique tous les robots
tout ce que vous voulez là les
américains les européens et même les
chinois ne sont pas forcément dominant
ce sont quelques entreprises qui
occupent le marché ça c'est alors les
allemands sont présents sur tout ce qui
est l'optique etc si mince à une
certaine présence mais les américains
par intel ont pas grand chose
les chinois he ont pas grand chose non
plus vous avez des boîtes à taiwan à tcm
qui est un géant taïwanais et que les
américains d'ailleurs attire sur leur
sol pour assécher en quelque sorte la
source de semi conducteurs pour les
chinois donc là on est dans la grande
bagarre
je pense qu'il ya enfin en europe et
stmicroelectronics qui nous reste
il faut absolument développer
stmicroelectronics 7 c'est vital pour
nous je dirais que tout n'est pas perdu
c'est une question de volonté et de
moyens si on met les moyens financiers
eh bien on arrivera je pense parce qu'on
a les ingénieurs on en a les hommes on
arrivera à si long à rattraper tout le
retard du moins à combler une partie du
retard sur le soft se fasse à amazon
évidemment et alibaba on n'a pas grand
monde
face à google on n'existe pas mais on
peut essayer au moins de protéger nos
données alors il y a
face aux américains ça sera un combat de
défensif et on peut sur les ordinateurs
je pense aux ordinateurs quantiques
notamment ce que fait bull ce que fait
atos
on a encore quelques quelques pépites
mais et puis il ya toutes les start up
mais start-up elles se font généralement
racheté par les gars femmes donc
peut-être qu'il faut les protéger et on
en arrive au problème du financement
il faut orienter l'épargné vers
l'industrie vers le développement
industriel vers les nouvelles
technologies vers la robotisation et c
est ça s'éteint c'était essentiel si on
oriente pas notre épargne les pagnes
française aussi d'epargne européenne
vers ces nouvelles industries et bien
effectivement on sera définitivement
largués sur l'agroalimentaire
quels enseignements ou tir du comider là
aussi la même question se pose faut-il
relocaliser certain nombre de
productions nicolas bouzou
dans l'agroalimentaire je pense que la
problématique à exactement celle de
l'indépendance et elle est pas celle du
co vite c'est une problématique qui est
un peu plus large qui est celle de la
façon dont on fait valoir nos avantages
compétitifs en france et dont on
valorise la qualité puisque c'est vrai
qu'en france on a une production
agroalimentaire qui a perdu 1 des parts
de marché ces dernières années mais
enfin qui reste quand même d'une qualité
tout à fait tout à fait exceptionnelle
et il ya une demande pour ça en france
et dans le monde c'est à dire que là
pour le coup autant je disais tout à
l'heure
s'ils ont des biens de consommation
courants ce pensent que la problématique
prix surtout ces prochaines années et
elle est absolument centrale et elle va
même être encore plus importante en
raison de la problématique
macroéconomique autant sur
l'agroalimentaire pour le coup je nuance
un peu mon propos je mets un peu
l'agroalimentaire de côté parce que là
je pense qu'il ya quand même dans
l'esprit des gens l'idée selon laquelle
la qualité a un coût et si elle a un
coût elle a un prix donc je suis un peu
plus optimiste sur 7 sur cette question
là alors est ce que ce sera des
relocalisations pas forcément d'ailleurs
un sapin avec le développement d
ailleurs déjà des productions agro
alimentaire en france on a un vrai sujet
qui est celui
l'organisation de notre agriculture en
agriculture qu'il fonctionne bien mais
vous savez d'agriculture c'est un
secteur
les gens imaginent peut-être une
certaine partie de la population puis
certain nombre de mes collègues dans le
débat public alimente un peu cette image
nostalgiques de l'agriculture avec un
agriculteur courbet qui traîne un
horaire derrière lui l'agriculture c'est
pas ça c'est un secteur de très haute
technologie - quand je parle de
l'intelligence artificielle de la
génétique de des technologies spatiales
dans des coopératives agricoles
connaissent tous pas d'après ce qu'ils
utilisent
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
génétique parce qu'elle avait été aux
précisions cette liste des technologies
spatiales parce que les tracteurs ses
détracteurs sans chauffeur avec des
capteurs absolument partout donc c'est
vraiment l'agriculture c'est un secteur
de très haute technologie et il faut
aider donc là encore ça passe sans doute
par des aides à l'investissement il faut
aider les coopératives à investir dans
les technos d'éventuellement à grossir
mais alors là vous voyez le problème
c'est que ça rentre un peu en collision
avec peut-être l'image nostalgique tu es
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens ont
de ce qu'ils imaginent être une
agriculture de qualité d'agriculteur
avec de petites d'exploitation la star
non c'est pas forcément ça lui avoir de
très grosses d'exploitation avec plein
de technologies
et c'est justement ça qui va permettre
de faire de l'agriculture a de très
bonne qualité à des prix qui même si ce
sont des prix un peu plus épais que
certaines productions à l'étranger sont
quand même compatible avec le pouvoir
d'achat des consommateurs français voilà
évidemment la question que je me pose
c'est est ce qu'on va avoir des phrases
de très bonne qualité ça veut dire des
très très bonne phrase est là qu est ce
qu il vaut mieux est ce qu'il vaut mieux
protéger les fraises françaises ou au
contraire ouvrir les frontières ouvrir
la concurrence et à voir les fraises les
meilleures possibles jean-michel 4
points oui les fraises françaises sont
meilleurs c'est bien connu mais
moi ce qui m'a toujours choqué dans
l'alimentation
c'est de voir arriver sur les étals le
mois de décembre
les cerises qui venait du chili les
pêches et les abricots qui venait
effectivement de l'hémisphère sud
bon j'ai été habitué à manger des fruits
au moment de la saison je pense que la
taxe carbone qui va se mettre en place
est un moyen de rétablir une certaine
concurrence
si vous avez des fraises qui viennent de
l'autre bout du monde qui sont moins
chers parce que les produits moins chers
avec la taxe carbone vous rétablissez un
peu les équilibres donc on va inventer
ça va se mettre en place dans ce cas
dans le cas de s'être continentalisation
vous est si grave et encourager une
forme de protectionnisme
jean-michel 80 points c'est aussi un
décor aux lyonnais de curieuses moi j'ai
toujours dans geodis
j'ai toujours j'ai toujours été pour la
préférence communautaire qu'on a
abandonné d'ailleurs mais je pense que
l'europe doit se protéger
oui communautaire
que l'europe doit se protéger et que les
normes sociales environnementales et
fiscales bah il faut rétablir
il n'est pas normal que des gens qui
produisent n'importe comment
puisses va en cassant les prix
de la même façon sur les normes sociales
de la même façon sur la fiscalité il ya
un minimum de règles à voir donc
bah oui il faudra établir ces règles ce
qui la régulation protectionnisme
national
vous leur dites quoi cela non mais non
menace nationale ça n'a malheureusement
ça n'a plus de sens aujourd'hui nous
sommes nous sommes l'espace schengen ne
vous n'allez pas fermer l'espace
schengen
vous vous croyez qu'on peut fermer
l'espace schengen non aujourd'hui la
libre circulation à l'intérieur l'espace
schengen on le voit bien avec le
tourisme v besoins du tourisme à
l'intérieur de l'europe
donc vous ne pouvez pas remettre des
frontières comme ça du jour au lendemain
les gens s'y sont habitués en plus alors
on peut discuter sur l'euro et c'est
tout mais je regrette
on ne peut pas remettre des barrières
comme il y avait 50 ans c'est pas
possible
l'angleterre le fait la grande bretagne
le feu l'angleterre est non mais
l'angleterre est là le commonwealth en
plus l'angleterre elle à la city c'est
une île en plus donc on peut pas on peut
pas comparer nous je vois pas si vous
voulez remettre les frontières au niveau
français encore une fois on est
tellement imbriquée notamment au niveau
européen
que du jour au lendemain ça serait un
cataclysme
il conclut à bezouce capitaux y compris
pour l'euro nicolas bouzou plus de
protectionnisme ça un sens pour vous non
parce que ça protège pas on vient encore
d'en avoir une illustration avec la
politique commerciale qui a été menée
par le président trump et il commence à
être bien documenté du point de vue
académique
emmanuel combe qui est l'un de nos
principaux spécialistes du commerce
international à regarder l'ensemble des
études d académie qui ont été réalisés
sur le sur le sujet est en fait ce qu'on
voit mais comme toujours avec le
protectionnisme c'est une très vieille
histoire mais c'est que en réalité il se
retourne
de façon assez pernicieuse d'ailleurs
parce que ça ne saute pas aux yeux mais
il se retourne contre ceux qu'il est
censé protéger est typiquement le
protectionnisme aux états unis
aujourd'hui donc il ya eu un certain
nombre depuis le mandat du budget de
l'ue hors d'elle prise d'empreintes et
un certain nombre de taxes qui soit se
retourne contre le consommateur parce
qu'on continue d'importer des biens des
pays desquels on a mis en place des
taxes
il n'y a pas de substitut mais du coup
on les achète plus cher et donc ça
diminue le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs créant d'ailleurs d'autres
types de problèmes économiques soir ce
sont des taxes
ils vont être payés par les entreprises
parce qu'elles vont importer par exemple
de l'aluminium est donc pour le secteur
de la construction ou de l'automobile
eh bien on va avoir une hausse des coûts
de production et donc in fine et ce
protectionnisme va dégrader la
compétitivité de deux pans entiers de
l'économie que le protectionnisme est
censé défendre et puis vous avez hostie
dans les mesures protectionnistes
souvent des mesures de rétorsion faire
que si vous mettez en place un
protectionnisme par exemple au niveau
européen
eh bien les autres zones c'est un petit
peu le schéma de guerre commerciale
qu'on a connu jusqu'à la crise ducobu
les autres zones vont aussi mettre en
place des politiques protectionnistes
et puis plus fondamentalement je pense
que enfin moi j'ai beaucoup plus
confiance que ça dans l'industrie
européenne
je pense qu'elle n'a pas besoin de
protectionniste je pense que on a un
terreau entreprenariale industriel
extrêmement sain extrêmement diversifiée
en europe et que
a moins besoin de ligne maginot que
d'incitation et d'encouragement donc je
pense que sans protectionnisme de toute
façon donne pas de résultat à l'ennemi
des rssi s'ils ne donnaient pas de
résultat ce serait un moindre mal mais
c'est plutôt qu'ils donnent des
résultats négatifs donc sans ce type de
politique on peut avoir des politiques
industrielles
ils sont extrêmement favorables à nos
intérêts économiques laisse juste un
tout petit mot sur la taxe carbone la
taxe carbone tu sais pas si c'est pas du
protectionnisme à moi je suis très
favorable à la taxe carbone parce que je
veux pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques mais ça permet d'internaliser
des coûts qui sont des coups qui ne sont
pas payés par les entreprises qui
polluent donc je suis très favorable
un marché carbone ou à une taxe carbone
mais c'est la taxe carbone c'est une
politique pour lutter contre les
émissions de carbone c'est pas une
politique protectionniste fait pour
industrialiser michel 4 points il n'a
pas l'air convaincu l'attaquant par là
par le protectionnisme même au niveau
européen nicolas bouzou il pense même
que ce serait contre-productif
oui mais moi je je je pense qu'il faut
rétablir les règles de la concurrence
et quand ya une concurrence faussée qui
n'est pas libre et la concurrence est
faussée notamment par encore une fois
sur des normes sociales
environnementales et fiscales
donc il faut rétablir des règles alors
ensuite je suis pas je n'aime pas
beaucoup les taxes non plus d'une façon
générale mais simplement on ne peut pas
accepter effectivement le dumping
quel que soit le dumping donc il faut
rétablir et au niveau européen je pense
que c'est la seconde c'est la bonne
dimension
alors ensuite il y aura avec les
américains peut y avoir des bras de fer
moi je trouve inadmissible qui
effectivement des américains s'arroge le
pouvoir de l'extraterritorialité leurs
droits et il faut trouver des moyens de
riposter à 7,1 période américain par
rapport aux chinois effectivement le
comportement des chinois leur arrogance
leur agressivité
depuis quelques temps n'est pas
acceptable donc il faut avoir les moyens
effectivement de pouvoir faire
éventuellement des bras de fer avec eux
dire qu'on n'est pas dans un monde de
bisounours
on est dans un monde de rapports de
force et les rapports de force il faut
les établir au niveau des continents
alors ce qu'on peut regretter c'est
qu'au niveau européen il n'y ait pas
effectivement une telle prise de
conscience et que depuis toujours
la france est la seule en fait avoir
milité pour une europe puissance et pour
une indépendance européenne alors qu'un
certain nombre de nos partenaires
européens eux se sont coulés dans le
moule effectivement d'un libre
échangisme absolue et totale y compris à
l'intérieur de l'europe avec tous les
dégâts que ça a causé nicolas bouzou les
eurosceptiques en général les partisans
du fric sites sont peu nombreux mais qui
pourraient devenir plus nombreux un jour
le défend tous peu ou prou la même idée
c'est que en étant pour le libre échange
contre le protectionnisme
au fond on ne défend pas l'intérêt
national que ce soit l'intérêt national
où l'intérêt des pays européens
vous êtes soupçonné vous avec ce qu'on
veut nous dire ce que vous dites de ne
pas défendre l'intérêt national dont
courage et une compétition où en gros
seuls les plus forts survivront et puis
tant pis pour ceux qui disparaîtront et
pourtant ça n'est pas ça ce que vous
dites
non bien sûr mais c'est une vraie
question c'est à dire que moi je pense
au contraire que la politique que je
prône elle est dans l'intérêt de la
france qu'elle est dans l'intérêt de
l'europe pourquoi je prends une
politique de puissance puissance
technologique puissance économique mais
je ne pense pas que cette puissance
elle passe par le fait de zik de
s'isoler mais je ne pense pas qu'elle
fois qu'elle passe par le fait de
construire des lignes maginot
je pense qu'elle passe par le fait
d'avoir des financements qui vont aller
à nos entreprises d'avoir une recherche
publique qui vient articulé avec une
recherche privée je pense que ça passe
par le fait d'avoir un marché unique
européen sur les technologies de la
troisième révolution industrielle et pas
27 marchés fragmentés
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui de telle
façon que j'ai certaines entreprises qui
sont implantées en france et qui ont
plus de facilité à exporter aux états
unis ou en chine plutôt que dans l'union
européenne parce que nous avons un
marché qui est fragmenté donc moi je
peux vous construire une politique de
puissance dans l'intérêt européen dans
l'intérêt français sans construire des
barricades qui nous serons pas ne seront
pas efficaces
je suis entièrement d'accord sur la
protection intellectuelle bien
évidemment que nous nous sommes fait
avoir sur les questions de protection
intellectuelle par rapport aux chinois
mais on y répond en traitant et en
mettant sur la table le dossier de la
protection intellectuelle pas en
augmentant les droits de douane sur je
ne sais quelle production la question
scandaleuse en effet de
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
mais c'est pas parce qu'on augmente les
droits de douane que le président trump
à mettre fin à l'extra territorialité du
droit américain c'est parce qu'on
arrivera à répondre sur le même sujet et
aux mêmes et au même niveau donc ceux
qui m'accusent de ça moi je leur retour
l'accusation c'est à dire que je pense
que c'est au contraire en nous
olemps qu'on nous affaiblit et c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sujet que nous avons
et vous avez évoqué le fric site
vous avez parfaitement raison mais c'est
tout le débat autour du break cite moi
je ne pense pas que le royaume uni se
soient renforcées en sortant de l'union
européenne je pense qu'il est en train
de passer sous la coupe américaine et
moi comme je suis un patriote un vrai je
préfère partager la souveraineté au
niveau européen plutôt que passer sous
la coupe de l'administration américaine
alors dernière question ben c'est sûr
renault évidemment on voit renault qui
est à la fois était déjà fragile avant
le qu'ovide 19 mai qu'il a demandé à
l'état français de lui et de garantir
l'emprunt de 5 milliards d'euros que la
régie renault va nous rappelle encore la
régie renault que renault veut dont
renault a besoin et en même temps qui
veut faire des économies
parce que ça suffit pas les 5 milliards
d'aud et supprimé des milliers d'emplois
mais ces milliers d'emplois renault veut
les supprimer en france pas en roumanie
pas à tanger en france qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
et là encore est ce que ça ça n'est pas
une entreprise qui veut continuer dans
la mondialisation telle qu'on la
connaissait avant je continue
d'externaliser surtout je m'en vais de
france progressivement jean-michel 4
points non mais renault comme d'autres
entreprises via le col vide la crise du
coc vide est plus dure pour ceux qui
étaient en mauvaise situation
toutes les entreprises qui étaient
fragiles vont prend en prendre plein
figure si je peux mais ferait ainsi et
renault était quand je compare à psa par
exemple renault était en position de
faiblesse
alors on peut est ce que c'est la faute
des dernières années de ghost est ce que
c'est la mise entre
à l'écart de ghost ilias à l'ombre de
raison est ce que c'est la faute du
management actuel de renault je pense
que tout ça ce que ce cumul est ce que
c'est
l'état actionnaire qui n'a pas joué son
rôle à un moment donné sans doute alors
ensuite je pense que renault avait en
tête déjà un certain nombre de plans
sociaux dans la tête et qu'il va
profiter effectivement de ceux du coc
vide pour accélérer le mouvement
donc on est dans une négociation ils
disent ah ben on risque de fermer quatre
usines dont flins et puis finalement ça
va se négocier par trois seulement en
gardant flins je vois un mot sur la base
et les batteries électriques qui sont le
dada de nicolas il a raison mais les
batteries électriques
on va renault va participer au programme
avec psa et valeo et c'est les autres
mais les batteries électriques c'est une
filière c'est un tout il n'y aura pas
d'industries européennes et françaises
de la batterie électrique
si derrière on n'a pas les matières
premières les matières premières celle
lithium s'est pas seulement le lithium
c'est le cobalt ainsi que l'on voit que
la politique industrielle
c'est un tout et que vous ne pouvez pas
simplement dire je vais mettre à
fabriquer des batteries mais je serai
dépendant de sources extérieures pour
des éléments essentiels que sont le
cobalt ou le lithium
donc c'est un tout il faut réfléchir à
la globalité alors pour revenir sur
renault je pense que l'entreprise
effectivement on peut lui demander de
rapatrier la fabrication des véhicules
électriques il ya une mutation tout les
ans toute industrie automobile va subir
une mutation profonde
le problème c'est comment on fait en
sorte que les millions de véhicules qui
existe et véhicules d'occasion continue
d'assurer à ce secteur une activité et
que on bascule progressivement sur le
véhicule électrique
ça ne se fera pas du jour au lendemain
faites cela prendre 10 ans 20 ans
l'automobile est complètement en train
de se transformer et la valeur de
l'automobile
elle est en train d'aller à la fois dans
l'infrastructure numérique presque on va
de plus en plus vers des voitures et qui
sont auto conduite vers des voitures
autonome
donc ça c'est pour l'essentiel de
l'informatique de l'intelligence
artificielle et
la valeur va aussi de plus en plus dans
la batterie parce qu'on va ces principes
c'est bien ou pas mais en tout cas de
fait nous allons vers une
électrification des voitures donc voyez
que la valeur elle va dans le numérique
et dans la batterie problème en france
ont fait part en europe d'ailleurs on
fait pas des batteries et
l'infrastructure numérique
elle est faite par les parlers
d'amérique qu'à donc on a un vrai et
sujet parce que on peut toujours
rapatrier des usines pour faire des
appuie tête mais ça va pas nous apporter
et où tous les emplois dont on rêverait
et avec les salaires dont on en rêverait
donc si on veut avoir une réflexion
prospective sur l'automobile
il faut quand même qu'on se dise on doit
construire des filières là où est la
valeur
c'est la raison pour laquelle en effet
j'ai plutôt de la sympathie pour le
consortium sur les yeux sur les
batteries électriques mais j'en ai
encore plus pour la construction de la
filière hydrogène parce que je me dis il
faut essayer d'avoir un coup d'avancé
cirque sur l'électrique le fond de ma
pensée c'est bien de le faire je
soutiens que ça mais dans un coin de ma
tête je me demande si là encore on
n'arrive pas un peu tard donc fois qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on ait une vision
prospective par rapport à ça je ne sais
pas si ce sera si ça aidera beaucoup
renault ça c'est vraiment un problème de
politique économique que nous avons en
nous soutenons beaucoup d'entreprises et
je pense qu'on a raison de les soutenir
mais en soutenant beaucoup d'entreprises
ont un soutien trop d'une certaine façon
c'est à dire qu'on soutient des
entreprises qui ont de magnifiques
perspectives à moyen euros et long terme
et on soutient aussi des entreprises qui
étaient en effet en grande difficulté
avant la avant la crise mais ça je
dirais pas que c'est facile à analyser
du point de vue théorique
quand on fait de la politique économique
de façon concrète
c'est très difficile de séparer le bon
grain de l'ivraie et donc on sait que
dans le tas si vous me passez
l'expression on gaspille forcément un
peu d'argent il faut arriver à les semer
on gaspille un peu d'argent si je vous
ai bien compris on est dans des
entreprises qui de toute façon été en
difficulté alors qu'on engage filet
quand on est du des entreprises qui sent
le coc vide ce serait porter très bien
je
cette émission est terminée je vous
remercie tous les deux d'y avoir
participé
je vous remercie également de nous avoir
suivis et je vous donne rendez-vous au
prochain numéro merci jean michel quatre
points merci nicolas bouzou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]